[Music]
anybody here enjoy going to all you can
eat places
oh yeah circus circus baby buffet you
have that mentality when they go there
like i'm gonna get my [ __ ] money's
worth i used to i used to used to i
would just taste them we used to we also
you see i bet if we all went to buffet
right now we'd all be like yo i'm
getting my 25 dollars worth yeah of crab
legs and crab rangus i go
i taste everything but i don't get
like stuffed and i'm gonna die anymore
yeah like i used to that's true yeah
back back when you counted every dollar
you eat a lot i would eat until i'm like
on the verge of throwing up and i'm like
okay this is what's the local buffet we
should do a shout out to all our local
buffets there's uh the one in glendale
the ba it's called vegas yeah it's
called vegas but basically i have one in
my hometown called king buffet yeah i
believe it's in courtland cortland new
york
you're out there anyone from king buffet
what's your favorite thing there what
was your favorite thing i love the
rangoons like crab rangoons [ __ ] love
them and then they had i don't know what
they're actually called but they they
called them chinese donuts
and they were basically just like dough
with like sugar on them yeah yeah yeah
those are chinese that's so thick i'm
like what's the chocolate it's a sugar
doughnut no no they're rounds they're
round they're around oh but they were
just i'm like what is this called they
almost look like beignets but it's not
powdered yeah and i'm expecting some
chinese name they're like chinese
doughnuts
i'm like no what is it really called
they're like don't [ __ ] worry about
it
don't [ __ ] worry about what it's
called don't [ __ ] what it's called
dude just [ __ ] eat it it's [ __ ]
you spend 25 bucks for all this [ __ ]
food
go get another donut king buffet [ __ ]
[ __ ] mouthing
welcome to new york where everyone has
an italian
there's a woman who actually ended up in
the hospital
after eating too much sushi at an
all-you-can-eat restaurant whoa it was
die how
tall
died did she get mercury poisoning
no she literally ate too much her name
is danielle shapiro she's 24 years old
and she went for a 50 ahead sushi buffet
in california where diners could help
themselves food as they like you know um
when they made it
you gotta eat the whole sushi my uncle
was probably the [ __ ] reason why they
started that rule because whenever he
got sushi he would just take the
the sashimi off and you just have a
whole plate of just rice and you would
leave it there oh [ __ ] son of a [ __ ]
that's ridiculous right see your uncles
my parents would have packed that rice
remember like see we have biryani that's
an indian rice dish
have they ever packed food at a buffet
my mom does
i don't know if you're allowed are you
actually allowed to i don't think i can
but my mom would do it oh she do it she
puts it in her purse my mom even
recently would have wanted to uh well
when i my dog was still alive uh she
would go to korean barbecue and then she
would take leftover meat put it in a
[ __ ] bag like a ziploc and take it
home from odd meat no no just like after
it's cooked and stuff like that yeah wow
my friend's mom had those massive ziploc
bags and then at the end of hometown
buffet they would get another round of
like fried chicken or whatever and she
would just stack that [ __ ] and then i'm
like that with red lobster biscuits ooh
cheddar baby biscuits i've never been a
red lobster oh it's good it's all right
no stop it everyone stop it stop don't
hurt my feelings like that dude red
lobster tv i love i'll [ __ ] love red
lips it's like really all right but do
you guys get made lobster at your red
lobster i mean now i will when i was a
kid when i was a kid probably not no
when i was a kid it was the popcorn
shrimp or and now and then as i got
became an adult it was the ultimate
feast oh the ultimate feast the red red
lobster but dude it was always for me
for at red lobster and people always
make fun of me about this like everyone
i bring this up to it's about the
margaritas and the [ __ ] biscuits you
go for the biscuits what's good about
the biscuits is it like a cornbread or
what is it it's just it's a cheddar
bay it's like a bay like old bay cheddar
biscuit that is just the texture is
perfect it's like soft and warm and it's
just like buttery to the point where it
like kind of sticks to the root of your
mouth but just
the texture they still do endless shrimp
that's seasonal wow you know red lobster
is one of those restaurants yeah
you guys ever grow up and you you felt
like certain things were out of reach
like red lobster was out of reach for me
because i was like that's baller [ __ ]
right
so then now that i went to restaurants
that are better
in my head red lobs are still out of
reach so it's not even on my radar
because you never reached it
you overreached so it's not even i never
even stepped foot in it because of that
reason i was like that's just too sacred
bro like it's too expensive yeah and
then like maybe i should go you should
cheat yourself out
from from like second grade to like
seventh grade my favorite restaurant and
i was like dude this is the bolorific
restaurant it was cheesecake factory
my brother went to school in baltimore
and his college had a cheesecake factory
next to it and they were like the weight
is seven and a half hours she's kicking
and we're like let's do it it's popping
dude it has the biggest menu it's a
wheat bread bro i remember coming back
and my third grade teacher mrs hartnett
being like what did you do this weekend
i'm like i visited my brother at school
and we went to the [ __ ] cheesecake
factory where all the students like
that person yeah
did you guys have a claim jumpers in the
east coast because that was the [ __ ] out
here when claims
when i was at high school yeah claim
jump they dude they give you [ __ ]
distortions it's like this
and that's like maybe my kid memory of
like how big the portions are i'm pretty
sure that's not the size it's pretty big
it's still huge as an adult right even
just the the mozzarella sticks remember
them shits the mozzarella sticks were
like [ __ ] dildos they're logs they're
dildos
i like that one so danielle
so danielle
who posts on tick tock right decided she
really wanted to get the value for money
so she chowed down on 32 sushi rolls
four gyozas one bowl of edamame beans
two jalapeno poppers and a bowl of miso
soup that's it it's 32 rolls sounds like
a lot like is it little rolls or is it
the whole actual like eight pieces this
is a roll of titanic because how many is
in one wait wait she had 32 i think
there are 16 or something like that yeah
is it 32 pieces or 32 holes no way that
[ __ ] 32 rolls dude is she a competitive
eater no but she went to the hospital
that's why if she was competitive that's
like 200 pieces she lost that confidence
that's a lot dude that's crazy she did
it for tick tock she she wasn't even
filming huh she well she did end up
tick-tocking some of it but i don't
think she necessarily did it for
tick-tock she did it probably because
she was like in that ambulance she's
like guys i did she did take something
she did no
um she had her stomach pumped so she
ended up having to go to hospital when
she woke up the next morning just
feeling all [ __ ] up uh and she had
gastroesophageal reflux disease oh so
it's coming up
the stomach acid was flowing back into
her esophagus
she should took some prevacid before she
went in there
so it could have been anything it wasn't
that it was fish it was just like she
just stopped herself to death amazing
she said her best friend amanda was in
town for the weekend and she loved sushi
so they were both looking forward to the
all-you-can-eat sushi experience and
since it's about 50 a person they needed
to make sure that they got their money's
worth and they ended up staying there
for over two hours because they were so
stuffed that they had to keep taking
breaks
there's no time limit this restaurant
doesn't have a time limit like every
good every good buffet has a timeline
yeah they know that they can't stay from
lunch to dinner
or breakfast at lunch they kick your ass
if that's her mentality about everything
and when she goes to the hospital she's
like i'm here i want to get my money's
worth let me let me get a [ __ ] boob
job
while i'm out
check me for colon cancer queen of deals
because they don't add prices onto that
you're already in there for one thing
what was interesting was she's like let
me just cut something so you have
something to fix the other uh the other
items that she got to make her 50 cause
i remember one time i went to an all you
can eat sushi and all i ordered was
unagi and uni because i wanted to hit
the thing and i was like nah they're not
going to give me unlimited eel and sea
urchin and they're like yeah we will but
it's one at a time a lot of those places
but you just got to order one and go i'm
ready for another one i'm ready for
another one that's it when you have one
piece at a time you can go until you die
yeah wow like you're like a dog because
you're like i can always do one you ever
got kicked out of all you can eat for
eating too much as a group i have not as
an individual like that but as like when
you're like a group of like six to eight
they're like hey you gotta you gotta
leave yeah why because you're standing
around talking too long or it's because
you're just [ __ ] putting them out of
business you're just saying dude when
you go with the crew you're eating too
much and you all have the same mentality
it's destructive eating yeah you're like
a tornado that just comes into the
restaurant and wipes them clean i bet
you see the worst of humanity working at
a [ __ ] all-you-can-eat restaurant
because everyone has that mentality i'm
gonna consume like i never consumed
before because when you go to all you
could eat sushi place with a bunch of
people you always get the one like we go
to the one where you mark it and they
give you one round at a time yeah yeah
the civilized exactly but when you go
with a bunch of people
everybody orders way too much on the
first round yeah it's almost like
overwhelming like you don't even need
more of that yeah you gotta eat the the
stuff that the other person does it yeah
because you gotta pick up for the
weakest link exactly why should you
order twice and then everyone's
co-conspirating to be like all right we
gotta hide the [ __ ] sushi
asian lady who's always just like that's
too much yeah yeah we're gonna start
with this
they're just dismissive she already
knows she's like idiots
asian joints do you want to know the
most legendary all you can eat place
where you'll see the worst of humanity
hawaiian gardens all you can eat kfc
they have all your hamsters kfc the only
one i've ever known about i don't even
know if it's just
where is it where is this wine garden is
this in hawaii no no there's like
there's a city called where is this
hawaiian
orange county polar opposite of hawaii
it's the shitty yeah it's right across
from the casino there's one kfc and we
used to go there and just eat from lunch
to dinner because they don't give a [ __ ]
and people are you know
people are like dying in there and
they're just like sitting there the
worst health you could i think we need
to do an episode there we need to go
there we need to do an episode there
dude seriously repent
if it's jk on location yeah if it's
still there i guarantee there's people
dying as hawaiian
no way that's
is there like a booth i mean like a
buffet bar yeah it looks exactly like a
buffet place but it's all just extra
crispy or original recipe oh extra
they're both options does any does
anyone choose original over extra crispy
nope um just seriously i do extra chris
i got extra like at least when i was
younger because it didn't matter to me
but now it's like that's a lot of bread
bro
but the crispiness this you want the
crispiness but yeah it's so original
soggy is it does it still exist no
it doesn't say anything about
specifically uh
kfc he never existed only in your dreams
this is a lie he's lying it was a fever
dream you know i missed i missed the
rotisserie goal really it was just like
a [ __ ] mcdonald's that is just
driving around it was just some guy's
house you get one chicken nugget at a
time just one
they bought the 20 piece but they drove
him around one nugget at a time
[Music]
you